- Mon fils a développé
une cyberdépendance...
- Programmeur-analyste
de formation et ministre
responsable de tout le volet
informatique du gouvernement,
Éric Caire connaît mieux
que quiconque les dérives
des écrans.
ÉRIC CAIRE, ministre délégué,
Transformation num. gouvern., Qc
- ... donc était accroc
à tous les jeux qu'on connaît.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ça a été jusqu'à se lever
toutes les nuits pour jouer,
pour être capable d'aller
chercher sa drogue.
Il s'est rendu très loin
là-dedans, très, très loin
là-dedans. Il est arrivé
un événement extrêmement
malheureux, grave, qui nous a
obligés à prendre des décisions
qui étaient absoluement
cruelles, sa mère et moi.
- Avec beaucoup d'émotions,
il nous raconte comment son fils
de 14 ans a dû être sevré
dans un centre de traitement
des dépendances, comme celui où
intervient Marie-Josée Michaud.
MARIE-JOSÉE MICHAUD, Centres
spéc. pour ados Le Grand Chemin
- C'est quelque chose qui a
une tendance à la hausse
présentement. C'est certain
que nos mesures sanitaires
sont venues un peu augmenter
nos facteurs de risque
pour l'ensemble de nos jeunes.
- L'école en ligne qui limite
les rencontre avec les amis,
elle constate les effets pervers
du confinement.
- Un volume d'appels plus
important, mais surtout,
je vous dirais, une détresse
plus importante de la part
des parents.
- Au-delà des campagnes
de prévention en cours,
le ministre Lionel Carmant
promet un plan d'action.
LIONEL CARMANT, ministre délégué
Santé et Services sociaux, Qc
- Ce qu'on veut, c'est trouver
la ligne où on peut permettre
l'utilisation de façon
sécuritaire et, en fait,
que ça devienne un outil positif
pour nos jeunes.
- 35 % des adolescents affirment
que leur utilisation des écrans
a nui à leurs résultats
scolaires. 45 % ont perdu
le sommeil pour cette raison.
Au point où la famille du quart
d'entre eux s'est inquiétée,
selon des chiffres colligés par
la santé publique de Montréal,
auprès de 700 jeunes
durant la 3e vague.
- C'est sûr que si on fait
juste dire aux jeunes :
"Lâchez vos écrans",
ça ne va pas fonctionner.
- Le chercheur Jean-François
Biron note que 25 % des ados
ont passé plus de 5 heures
par jour sur les écrans
durant leurs temps libres
au printemps dernier.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS BIRON, Direction
régionale de santé publique, Mtl
- Les parents ont un rôle,
évidemment les milieux scolaires
ont un rôle de mettre
en place les bons paramètres
pour l'encadrement.
- D'ailleurs, dès cet automne,
dans chaque école secondaire,
il va y avoir des intervenants
en dépendance et différents
organismes communautaires.
Et on veut qu'ils participent
à cette promotion de
l'utilisation saine des écrans.
- Il faut documenter ça
et il faut s'assurer que
les parents vont être outillés,
puis que les jeunes vont
avoir les ressources.
- Des ressources qui ont permis
de traiter son enfant.
- Il est capable d'identifier
quand ça devient...
quand ça devient excessif.
Mais ça, c'est un processus
qui prend du temps.
- Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada,